[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qui depuis est devenu une femme voilà et
qui s'appelle
et en fait le succès de cette série
c'est parce que c'est un mix entre
famille XXL et le glamour et on a pu
assister en fait à la construction de
cet empire mais c'est vraiment un empire
dans la mode le maquillage etc elle a
fait plus d'oseille que tout le monde
avec ça
les petits sont déjà dans les vidéos et
dans les qui peuvent être Kardashian et
donc du coup supposer que les petits
il y a 14 ans quand ça a été lancé il y
a 14 ans maintenant ils étaient
ridiculisés ils étaient là honte les
quarts de la route bien sûr quand on
arrive à Los Angeles il y avait partout
Kardashian family etc c'était la honte
il y avait pas pire au monde que les
Kardashian tout le monde se foutait de
leur gueule et maintenant ce sont des
superstars ils sont toutes milliardaires
mener effectivement pour la maman qui
est redoutable
avec Pierre désolé pierre mais mais
j'avais hâte qui reviennent ils ont
arrêté en 2020 ils ont déjà créé le
manque en un an et demi c'est incroyable
un coup de génie et dans la rue sur les
Kardashian je suis désolé et dans le
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi parce que comme il a pas de
fille il est pas Fatou à la maison faut
pas qu'ils y stress
et dans la guerre des plateformes c'est
un coup de génie de Disneyland je lui ai
donné quand même que Disney plateforme
pour les enfants
qui sont un peu sulfureux entre le père
qui est devenu madame les les filles qui
ont du plastique dans les fesses
c'est-à-dire c'est aussi famille XXL
donc c'est la famille donc c'est les
enfants donc c'est qui viennent qui s'en
vont etc et puis il y a le côté valeur
famille et malgré tout et en plus et ça
et le luxe qui fait rêver le glamour les
jets privés et vas-y vas-y c'est un peu
bigarden life quoi
parce que toutes ces écolos d'ailleurs
ça fait bilan carbone des Kardashian
alors là alors
là
on va avancer
d'accord avec Pierre je comprends pas le
positionnement de Disney entre la sexy
de Tommy
bien sûr
et puis d'un seul coup là
tu m'avais pas manqué
Gilles est un immense paradoxe on ne
sait jamais où il va se poser voilà vous
êtes surprenant quand même vous êtes
surprenant c'est votre temps à taper sur
ce qui compte l'oseille vous adorez les
Kardashian mes goûts sont éclectiques